avec nous ce soir Georges juju président
directeur général de Galileo global
Advisor bonsoir Monsieur jeu
bonsoir Monsieur Fillon est-ce que la
chute de crédit Suisse est un problème
pour vous qui est circonscrit qui ne
concerne que Crédit Suisse ou s'est
révélateur d'une fragilité bancaire plus
étendue
écoutez il y a une différence entre
reconnaître des fragilités d'une banque
et voir effectivement si c'est le
secteur qui est en cause moi je suis je
vous l'avoue extrêmement paisible et le
Crédit Suisse ne m'empêche pas de dormir
pour une raison bien claire c'est que
finalement
l'importance de cette banque fait que la
Suisse ne va jamais laisser tomber le
Crédit Suisse il va peut-être y avoir
des pertes de valeur chez les
actionnaires mais le crédit 6 comme
votre collègue l'a dit à une longue
histoire de problème dans sa direction
dans son organisation et donc le crédits
si vous voulez porte le poids du secteur
en Europe parce que effectivement le
Crédit Suisse a un problème mais le
Crédit Suisse ne va pas tomber
pensez-vous d'autant que la Banque
nationale suisse la banque centrale d'y
être prête à intervenir
le Crédit Suisse n'a pas de problème de
solvabilité
le Crédit Suisse s'il y a des
difficultés risquent d'avoir des
problèmes de liquidité et c'est là que
l'intervention de la Banque nationale
suisse va résoudre le problème donc
c'est pour ça que je vous dis il n'y a
pas de risque de chute du Crédit Suisse
il y a des remous les banques centrales
vont faire ce qui est nécessaire il est
hors de question que le crédit fiston
parce que les effets dans l'ensemble du
système serait pire que 2008 donc on
n'est pas du tout on a quand même
beaucoup travaillé pour essayer de
renforcer le système bancaire et dès
lors je ne crois pas aujourd'hui mais je
comprends les investisseurs qui se
disent bon je vais ne pas investir ou
vendre le maillon fait je voudrais
réagir à la réaction des deux
actionnaires importants
je crois que le crédit suis va devoir
résoudre son problème de fonds propres
et elle en a un nom et elle a le temps
de le faire elle va le faire autrement
qu'en faisant une augmentation de
capital
ce n'est pas en demande aux actionnaires
maintenant d'ajouter de l'argent qu'on
va résoudre il faut d'abord résoudre ces
problèmes en interne il y a des
activités que le créditisme peut vendre
et elle peut reconstituer ses fonds
propres d'une manière qui n'implique pas
d'aller dans la poche des actionnaires
donc j'entends bien là dans vos
explications que le Crédit Suisse a ses
enjeux il doit s'occuper de ses enjeux
que la Suisse ne va certainement pas
laisser tomber Crédit Suisse qui quand
même la deuxième banque en importance
cela dit est-ce que le véritable danger
il est celui de la confiance de la
crainte des investisseurs qu'il y a un
domino de de turbulences financière
qu'il y ait des retraits massifs dans
certaines banques et qu'il y a donc une
nouvelle crise financière qui se
déclenche
écoutez j'essaye d'être et vous savez
que je ne suis pas un optimiste
à tout craint quand on regarde
l'évolution des marchés je vais vous
dire qu'ici il y a un risque d'amalgame
signature banque on la liquidé pour des
raisons de crypto
a fait des bêtises d'investissant ne les
a pas comptabilisés comme il fallait ils
vont devoir rendre mais par exemple pour
donner un exemple sur les 25 milliards
de d'actifs qu'ils avaient en vente du
Trésor c'est 25 milliards sont chez GEP
Morgan donc je dirais on va dépecer la
silicone ceux qui vont payer la facture
cette fois-ci ce ne sera pas le
gouvernement ce sera les actionnaires et
les détenteurs d'obligations cela vont
probablement perdre beaucoup d'argent
par contre maintenir les clients et les
dépôts ça c'était essentiel à l'activité
économique mais je répète quand même
est-ce qu'il y a un danger de panique et
de nouvelles crises financières
le problème de la panique c'est qu'il y
a toujours un danger il n'y a pas un
excès de confiance mais personnellement
je ne considère pas que ceci est un
problème systémique et donc je ne crains
pas une un effet de contagion qui
pourrait déstabiliser l'ensemble du
secteur parfait explication très claire
Georges Huger je vous amène sur les taux
d'intérêt parce que là face à toute
l'incertitude les marchés envoient des
signaux non plus de hausse de taux
d'intérêt mais de baisse le taux
d'intérêt aux États-Unis à la fin de
2023 vous vous attendez à quoi ce qu'il
faut s'attendre à ce que la fête ne
monte plus ces taux d'intérêt
non vous avez très bien vu que ce sont
des bons du Trésor donc c'est la dette
américaine ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui c'est que tous ceux qui ont
voulu
sortir des dépôts ont acheté des
obligations ça c'est passé en 24 heures
c'est donc un effet direct de
déposant dans le secteur bancaire qui
ont préféré prendre des bons du Trésor
et ça ça a été le problème et c'est une
réaction assez naturelle la réalité
comme l'a dit Jay Powell c'est que les
taux d'intérêt vont remontés on va
retrouver le niveau heureusement
l'inflation n'augmente pas trop mais
elle est toujours là donc je ne pense
pas que ceux-ci sont un changement de
politique ceci c'est plus une
conséquence de la recherche si vous
voulez parler déposant américain de ce
qu'on appelle un cfarbor c'est à dire un
endroit où leur capitaux sont sans
risque et ils ont choisi les bons du
Trésor donc hausse de taux pensez-vous
la semaine prochaine
on va revenir vers les en tout cas sur
le 2 ans on va revenir très proche de 5%
du taux directeur de la Réserve fédérale
je veux dire la semaine prochaine
ah oui ça de toute façon c'est prévu et
pour être très honnête
ceux qui viennent se passer
continue à rendre important la
restructuration de l'économie américaine
et la lutte contre l'inflation
Georges merci toujours un plaisir de
vous accueillir merci beaucoup
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI